i hope everyone enjoyed their holiday we
have a great interview with andrew
schultz coming up we just got back from
new york city we went to new york
for a few days uh to see my parents to
surprise
both of my parents to do a socially
distanced uh
truncated holiday which is really the
way i want to do them from now on
10 minutes socially distanced you're
live i'm alive okay
cool bye we're out of there i surprised
my mother who's in a mental institution
by the way
everyone's like she's going to be so
surprised i'm like she's insane it's not
gonna be that much of a surprise
every day she they just go today is
another thing and she goes
okay she's in an institution i'm sure
she was
i'm sure the level of surprise was
somewhat muted you know
i was i told her i said i'm sorry trump
lost she felt very bad about that she
goes i know i know
and we gotta do it through a plate of
glass like she's a felon
because of corona so i gotta covet
whatever you gotta stand i like corona i
like calling it the old school yeah i
like that
i gotta stand outside the plate glass
window and then she kept demeaning ben
she kept going i was like yeah ben's my
co-producer she's like oh you're
secretary
like not really he's he edits all my
content she's like your secretary i'm
like well
my best friend she's like your secretary
he's a secretary
like well you know certainly some of his
duties
are secretarial i mean there's you know
but
you you you took it in stride she's a
lovely woman
you took it in stride i think she
thought it was funny to keep calling me
a secretary i could see her smiling yeah
well you you you need to be beaten and
people
realize that if someone gives you too
many compliments
the things you will do the horror you
will bring upon the world
would be uh unquantifiable this is true
the nightmares that you if you are not
constantly made to feel bad about who
you are
you are not at your best true it's true
it's a fact
some people just need it and then we
went to see my father
and uh the woman he married those two
goons
they just uh built a new house uh they
didn't build it they bought a new house
two blocks away from their old house
because they were bored
during the quarantine and because as
always they have no money and they're
perpetual victims and life is hard
so they bought a new house that's big
not as big as my house that doesn't
matter
it does and they uh
they're living there now in a lovely
idyllic kind of
town you know we go there we surprise my
father
you know the first thing he says he
looks at me goes you know what's so nice
here
he goes during the summer the kids all
throw water balloons at the fire trucks
on the fourth of july he goes it's real
americana i'm like oh that's nice why
didn't we live here when i was growing
up
why didn't you give a [ __ ] about that i
was growing up doing cocaine
at 13 years old in in my best friend's
house whose mother was a prostitute
and we were doing blow where was your
care about americana back then
where was santa claus in the fire truck
back then you didn't give a [ __ ]
now you care that you're 70 and you have
no children
him and his chick their kids are gone
they've all been raised and they're out
of the house now they've decided to get
a
what a great place to raise ours no
children
what a great place to raise our dogs our
dogs and then my stepmother who i've you
know we've had
issues but i mean we're fine you know i
you know i have no issue with anybody
but she likes to dig she digs
and many of you know this because you
have family members that do this they
give a compliment
which is actually uh the worst thing
you've ever heard
they give you a compliment and then
follow it up with the meanest someone
can be to you
they try to find your weaknesses isolate
them and then attack
which is what the woman does she she
started with me she goes oh you gotta
you got a nice big house i said yeah she
goes
are you all alone there
she doesn't even ask like that she goes
like that she goes first she goes
so does ben live with you i'm like no
ben lives with his wife and
oh she goes oh so you're alone in the
house i'm like yeah i'm a lunch because
does it get lonely there
and i'm like no it's fine i like it's i
live alone a lot of people live alone
doesn't it's not a big deal but she's
just going she's digging in
and then she goes at him she goes she
goes so you
work with him she goes how did you meet
he goes why why he was a comedian and
elijah goes
oh so you used to do comedy because you
don't really do comedy anymore
and ben's like no my desk well he works
with tim and they do this whole thing
and
she goes oh so you don't do your own
comedy
anymore like again just trying to needle
and then he it starts to work on him
he starts to get like sad he goes i'm
just a laugh track
i'm just a laugh track that's all i do
and i'm like god damn it no
don't let her do this then she starts
talking about her own daughter she goes
my daughter lives in a small apartment
and doesn't have any friends
she goes the law firm's keeping her very
busy but she doesn't have any friends
because she hasn't lived in long island
in a decade
and the only joy in her life is when me
and your father take her out for dinner
i'm like well i'm sure that's not true
i'm sure that's completely untrue and if
she's having such a hard time of it in
life
why are you telling me this god
keep it in but she likes that she likes
to spread
horror she does i mean that's just what
it is and poor little ben
was like i'm like ben runs our company
ben does everything
and ben was just like i'm just a laugh
track
i'm just a laugh track that's all i do
and i'm just like where you could tell
she's she doesn't work on me i don't
care i go yeah i like being alone
and then we start telling them about
patreon and all the money that we make
and everything
just because i would never do that but
the way i i only behaved in that manner
because she
it angered her it angers them when i
talk about money
that angers them right um
[Music]
but but we were in and out of there what
10 minutes
yeah 10 minutes both of us thoroughly
insulted
and this is what you this is what you
can do instead of doing the whole
holiday party
because holidays are fun if you have
little kids and you give them batman
daddy i love you that's not it for a lot
of us for a lot of us it's going to a
family
sitting around a room with a bunch of
people with drinking problems and
divorcees multiple bankruptcies people
don't even know who each other are
anymore
you're like who are you again you're
dating who
you're your uncle
[ __ ] rick's girlfriend you've been
seeing each other how long like
no one knows you it's like it's also i'm
a divorced family so i don't even know
the uncle whose girlfriend this is
like uh yeah i'm sharon i date steve
who's steve
what are we all doing here it's a waste
of our time
everybody's like one you know we're all
like somehow
this is just odd configuration of human
beings in
uh a divorced family where people have
several marriages and different children
it's some have you ever been at these
holiday parties where like
the kids come in after they were with
their other
family this is true it's like the
saddest thing
it's like and now the kids are back from
dads
and the kids run in all manic and they
and they have to start like they fling
their jackets off and then they grab
their presents
and then they like they're like i'm now
i'm enjoying my second
christmas with this other family i
really don't know
it's so weird and then they introduce
the kids to you
and you're like hey whatever their names
are you know
hey ralph no one's named ralph but you
know what i mean i don't
there's too many of their real names for
me to use even though i do talk about
i don't know why i'm shielding the
children but i feel like it just makes
sense
but then you look at them and they're
like you know some i love like the
the the girls who are kind of [ __ ] like
the like girls and they're like early
teens or whatever
they're like this is tim this is timmy's
son and they just go like this oh
you know and i'm like yeah merry
christmas
mary i don't know why i'm here merry
christmas i hate
this
it's such a i mean the christmases have
just gotten tragic
and then people you barely know hand you
garbage gifts
they hand you [ __ ] gifts my stepmother's
father once gave me a hard drive i'm
like what is this
the zapruder film it was [ __ ]
he goes it's it just says all these
facts because you're a comedian you
should know a bunch of facts
it was just endless pages of facts about
everything you could think about
really yeah i'm like what the [ __ ] is
going on here
what is this
but you don't know these people and they
shouldn't even be giving you gifts and
yet they
are you just fall out
of families you fall out like i said to
ben like ben is my family because like
my mom's not
i'm like dad i love him but he's had a
lobotomy i mean he's been mcmurphy he's
talking about his dogs and then his wife
maleficent is trying to ruin our lives
here
she's trying to just destroy any
semblance of self-respect me and this
kid have
and then i i i choose that or my lunatic
mother
you know in a stop the steel hat with
tina 40.
so and i know and my cousins am i cut
listen to this my cousin
okay the ones that aren't in jail
currently
texts me and goes hey i don't ask for
much by the way
good i don't ask for anything
so when you go i don't ask for much i go
good please don't change that
please have that be the only text hey i
don't ask for much
oh noted merry christmas
but then he goes like this i'm gonna
read the text
it's out of his goddamn mind these
people
and i love everyone and respect them but
i have to let everyone know
listen to this listen throwing this
out there i don't ask for much i don't
have a twitter and budweiser is doing
this thing
if you send them a pic of your dog they
will put it on their beer can
can you send this picture to budweiser
and send the hashtag
pupwiser hashtag put what
aren't you in recovery why do you want a
dog on a
can of budweiser what's the next thing
you want me to do get a picture of your
dog on a syringe
you want an oxycont with a picture of
your cat get to work
folks i've had enough
then he goes you know i'll save the
trouble if you answer i'll just go [ __ ]
myself correct
love the little guy but enough no i'm
not putting your dog on a can of
budweiser
many people in our family have wet brain
because of that product
okay there's people that can't stand up
straight without getting vertigo
yeah i don't think we should put your
puppy on a beer bottle
enough with the substances for christ
[ __ ] irish slobs won it all